we now know who president Trump is
considering as his next chief of law
enforcement and it's a man who has done
that job before chief White House
correspondent John Roberts is here to
tell us who that is from the North Lawn
good even John Beckett evening to you
for the past several weeks President
Trump seemed in no hurry to replace Jeff
Sessions permanently even though he had
all that criticism about the interim
Attorney General Matt Whittaker but
suddenly this afternoon
word that the president had settled on a
candidate one who has enjoyed broad
bipartisan support sources tell Fox News
that President Trump wants William Barr
to be his next Attorney General if
nominated it will be a second tour of
duty for bar he served as attorney
general during the George HW Bush
administration a whiz kid from Columbia
University in George Washington
University Law School Barr was just 42
when he first became Attorney General
while President Trump doesn't know Barr
they do have one thing in common
Barr fully supported the president's
decision to fire FBI director James
Comey last year the president is
entitled to his choices FBI director and
while I admire Jim Comey a lot I think
he's contributed a lot to the country
he's enormous enormous ly gifted he
crossed the basic line back in July
fundamental line in the department as
the president looks set to give Barr a
thumbs up the stock market turned thumbs
down today on the us-china trade
relationship the reason for the swoon
this time the arrests Saturday of Huawei
CFO moong wanju Huawei is China's
largest telecom company and America's
chief competitor for new 5g systems that
will revolutionize everything from cell
phones to self-driving cars to robotic
surgery at the request of the United
States mueng was arrested by Canadian
authorities in Vancouver the BOJ has
been investigating huawei's possible
violation of Iran sanctions and wants to
extradite mung China is protesting
loudly convoy a junior China demands
them to immediately clarify the reason
for the arrest release the detainee and
safeguard the legitimate rights and
interests of the detainee the arrest was
made on the same day president Trump was
having dinner with Chinese President Xi
Jinping in an attempt to move us Chinese
trade relations forward the White House
says President Trump did not know about
the arrests before his meeting with Xi
national security adviser John Bolton on
NPR today well you know there are a lot
of things that are pending at any given
time you don't know exactly what's going
to happen in terms of a particular law
enforcement action
Boulton added that Huawei has long been
suspected of involvement in intellectual
property theft enforced technology
transfer on behalf of the Chinese
government I think this is going to be a
major subject of the negotiations that
President Trump and President Xi Jinping
agreed on in the - errors Huawei has
been attempting to dominate the global
5g infrastructure but fearing everything
from intellectual property theft to
outright espionage - some countries
including New Zealand Australia and
Britain are either eliminating or
limiting their use of Huawei products no
word yet on whether mungs
arrest is going to have any impact on
the pending us-china trade talks
Brett John Roberts loved the North Lawn
John thanks